why are we friends on the dick Sherlock
Holmes are you just sitting there he's
hurting and I'm sitting here stop dry
humping the doorknob was like right
there a ha ha why aren't you wearing a
shirt
Sara we're together sexual power oh we
need oxygen
oh yeah our like our hero I almost died
we'll go back to that engine hold on
whoa are you doing I'm doing that I'm
doing the secrets bullets this is my
hundred percent playthrough where I get
every single item except for those ten
that I just made look and then she was
like nah though and then and then we got
back together for a week all right and
then and then she's like like I can't
have a boyfriend in my life right now
I've got too much going on I'm gone on
your home all day staring at your
ceiling and texting people and eating
cookies like what else are you got going
on it's the same asian dude wait I still
don't have a helmet look how did I walk
out in space without dying I'm
technically a room space each its way
into him how do I walk out on the
surface of Mars without dying very fixed
it usually you feel better now um looks
like stuffs happening what that guy
really lost his head eh
hey buddy yeah what the hell
what kind of porn are you watching man
Oh No
is this a did I forget to take off my 3d
glasses dude this 3d of the best now on
4d with punch Oh vision oh I'm being
shot he's got a gun
the feel of being shot it's so immersive
just 3ds to 3d I'm going home
he said I can't even right now it was
this directed by James Cameron look like
his face it kind of looks like he just
has that facial structure yeah I'm being
the monster oh it's it take that in
Russia now we got Russia whoa this floor
is doomed just go just get out of here
there's no hope there's no hope for you
writing your breasts because your oxygen
going down really fast this guy must
have strong lungs you must be used to
not being able to breathe for like a
minute and a half at a time
well he is kind of like a marine I was
making a joke about like second deck
okay
whoa hey go skull
that'll change the subject hey man what
are you doing over there
bums and willies bollocks
oh can I have your helmet
there we go need to make sure he was
skeletal fine so where is this flash my
god that was gut-wrenching oh man that
was adorable
I swear that was two puns at once I'm
going to kill you you should Jackson's
out there somewhere just throwing up all
over himself hey it's the guy with no
face again hey come on man time you face
facts this needs to be an out the audio
of this is just people screaming other
comics other doors oh well don't go that
way
geez the stuff you have to do to get a
bridge working good lord
Oh monster closets this is what I was
talking about huh it's not really
it's a quiet they trapped in the closet
hug you down my gun he's bobbing and
weaving this guy knows two maneuvers
he's too fast I can't get a bead on him
whoa hey that guy just climbed out of
the wall
this is dead space all over again it's
like that time this happened was yelling
it help Oh aah what help look if there
was a guy up there baby and I know he
did he did no it's fine dad I'm the hero
man though whoa whoa whoa I don't want
falling there girl look at them Pistons
wow that really grinds my gears damn it
oh yeah back you savages
I'm trying to think of another pun but I
can't because fear oh we should play
fear next that's a first-person survival
horror game with stupid stuff in it I
hope no one shoots those explosive
barrels while I'm walking through here
and explodes ah ah hey that climb in
here and servo I'm on fire I want to
climb in this crawl space and then just
live there forever ah Jesus Christ oh
it's jack he's evil
shoot him damn it he's fire balls I'm
gonna sidestep you're fireball this
guy's too fast I want this guy to just
like be talking on a radio Jesus Christ
ah damn it time every every time I turn
a corner ah every time without fail what
I'm on the radio with this guy and he
says there's a situation on level one
like that
does the situation have good abs that is
really buff but he stole out wait which
way whose girlfriend did Snooki steal I
know he stole someone's girlfriend right
stuck you the girl wait really
oh hey Nosferatu
wait what huh enter combination wait I
saw a thing right here maybe if I read
it
oh I'm mildly dyslexic apparently ah I
did it
crying echo step four Steve bloom who
sounds like Wolverine on someone sneezed
a lot of blood you ever had that thing
happened we're like you're not paying
attention and then something really
important happens and then you just kind
of like mildly glanced up at it and then
you know Oh even though you should be
like scared shitless you're just like oh
it's like I mean I take a second to
start texting in the middle of class and
then the fire alarm goes off and
everyone falls out of their chairs and
the teacher seriously just like like
dives halfway across the room and I'm
just sitting there looking at my phone I
go Oh stuffs happening stuffs happening
that's what happened just now that guy
sure could have used the leg up this guy
kicked the bucket I gotta hand it to
that oh my god the pond monster Manny
this just a barrel ass yeah yeah I'm an
action hero you see that how was radical
wasn't good he was a ghost here you want
to play good no you should play now
you're just sitting over there playing
games on your phone man this is called
let's ignore not let me ignore there's
multiple of us you gotta be
participate participating huh are you
yes you really though how are you pretty
explain to me carefully why you're
participating what why should I give you
the raise over Jackson
why are you employee of the month
because I'm here
fair enough Jackson you've been verbally
destroyed oh I can't stray bullets
apparently my weakness my one weakness
just halo well with zambese look that
guy shot me with a gun this isn't scary
I mean is jumpy I'm jumpy man
will you stop being an Arab why I'm very
I'm just gonna beg you climbing up this
murder ladder we're climbing up the
stairs climbing up the stairs climbing
up the stairs climbing
olá is that helmet oh god damn it man
I'm basically Gordon Freeman climbing
around in these vents are u s-- climbing
through the vents climbing through the
vents alone what's this what the vents
climbing to the fence fence oh look
there's stuff down there weird cuz when
they're wearing a helmet you can't even
tell there's a'm be a just feel like I'm
being shot by some guy who's secretly
like a serial killer and he's in the
Marines and he's like man I wish some
kind of situation would go down right
now that would give me an excuse to just
shoot anyone I saw on site well damn it
surely you know what's playing is that
guy didn't that guy didn't make any
attempt to shoot at me he was just
walking around for all I know that guy
couldn't have like not been a monster
and I just know just what makes you any
different from me oh no playing to him
three man is with we have four minutes
left to make this entertaining quick
what do we do let's let's just let's
just play the wait I have an idea
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
doesn't fix everything
[Music]